incroyable écroulé alors attendez on va
recommencer on va tout petit peu pâle et
nous amuser que l'avenir des ménages
alors elle et lui donner un supplément
d'âme je sois et de quelle façon
et de quelle manière écoutez moi je
connais bien il disait que ninive allait
disparaître sous les eaux et puis
finalement il s'est plaint colonies ni
venez pas disparu sous les eaux je crois
pas au grand prophète du grand soir je
crois pas à cette espèce de déversement
de hargne de bill et de haine je crois
que le monde va grosso modo vers quelque
chose qui s'appelle la picardie nc je
pense que mon client c'est notre
problème est que vous êtes yeux
extrêmement s'instaure la planète mais
calendrier chacun de retrouver ses
parents
monsieur sco group
vous êtes haineux et moi je peux vous
dire que moi l'avenir on l'invité je
pense que le grand message que j'ai
envie de donner à l'avenir c'est un
message d'amour parce que moi j'ai trois
enfants et ils vont vivre cela et vous
vous avez simplement une tombe bureau de
haine et d'injures à déverser je vous ne
connaissez pas vous m'avez agressé vous
avez même pas qui je suis et vous me
traitez d'agen d'astria mais c'est
incroyable vous êtes haineux et ceci est
vraiment comprends pas que vous soyez à
ce point tombe heureux comme ça de haine
noah et vous pas réellement et vous pas
réellement avec une espèce de haine qui
est incroyable et vraiment je suis hors
de moi
belle frayeur sinon j'aurais simplement
dire une chose une seule chose je crois
que la vie est compliquée le monde est
complexe il se globaliser sujet sur les
ondes et bien et la voix porte en verre
de choses qu'ils ont perdu plus et je le
serai là comme ce soit et comment